madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Commissaire je souhaite féliciter la
Commission européenne pour le premier
examen volontaire de l'Union européenne
sur les progrès réalisés dans la mise en
œuvre des objectifs de développement
durable nous mesurons tout le chemin
accompli cependant nous pouvons aller
plus loin et nous devons faire mieux
atteindre les odd c'est améliorer la
qualité des sols de l'eau de l'air et
prévenir les aléas climatiques ces
garantir l'accès à une eau potable par
le renouvellement des réseaux de
distribution atteindre les odd c'est
aussi augmenter la production agricole
locale par la diversification des
cultures et la création de nouvelles
unités de transformation
atteindre les odd c'est enfin accélérer
le déploiement des énergies
renouvelables par la multiplication
d'éoliennes des panneaux solaires ou
encore des centrales géothermiques en
fonction des atouts des territoires
par notre vote demain nous témoignerons
de l'engagement politique de l'Union
européenne et nous demanderons à la
commission d'élaborer une stratégie
politique pragmatique et un plan de
financement adapté